hello and welcome to see you're playing
a short average that's funny kid exactly
the same thing as the last game yeah but
I cannot resist you go into a king's
indian it's um usually just a
comfortable opening for wine okay so you
probably try some early f5 stuff and one
reason why i like to go here to the
king's indian is that i'm not i'm really
not much of an expert on them on the
white side of the modern or pelts
defense yeah g4 here is early but it
still I think makes quite some sense
okay so g5 I don't my dad limiting
black's pieces here okay isn't g5 and g6
awfully weak now okay if I go nite a
three-night g4 maybe okay I think I'll
investors movie age three then my next
moves are night at three root g one and
I don't see how he deals with the porn
on g6 it looks so very difficult to do
okay so I don't okay yeah it's
interesting 95 it's not so easy to play
mm-hmm and Bishop g2 was not really what
I wanted to do with this
I should have thought about it when she
won a little bit probably this is not
ideal I still have doubts about blacks
position in the long run but that wasn't
a good um a very good development for me
there certainly was something on better
okay
it's as issue then what would help them
enormously if you would get something to
have for him Castle him so now maybe he
wants to go g5 and night to g6 hmm when
I was playing Queenie to I will ensure
this is right or Queen d2 is right so
maybe Queen d2 would have been better
okay well it's not clear how good she
five actually is so on g5 slf 22 yeah
but this I I didn't think is
strategically advisable I saw that but I
felt it cannot be good because of the
light squares are absolutely week now
this should be six for example is
looming like Knight takes pawn takes and
then why night might go to gym dd5 now
we'll see i felt that this is a bit too
risky for black and snatching this pawn
okay can just go Queen g2 here I wonder
if that helps
yeah let's do it
yeah now this is the thing bishop is six
it's definitely not bad but maybe you
can just ignore it play rookie seven or
something taking should be pretty nice
for white yeah so he he did take it he
didn't take it sorry um yeah but now
need to double on the gphone I think
yeah he will take take it at one point
inspected for sure yeah I was thinking I
this is good compensation but it's two
points now answer I'm not totally sure
well I will get something back maybe
it's got no g5 i will take king is on b1
so there's no trickery and i'm not sure
that it was worth two points but it's
worth something that's quite clear i
will get 1 point back for sure
ok
oh wow it's dangerous bishop age 6
Bishop interesting saw some other move
Bishop e3 is also possible Wi-Fi go
Bishop to e7 I mean yes 10 years we've
got seven what's the best learning this
query here Bishop age six route takes
root g 7 9 x's just about surviving this
how to believe a key i have to play move
it would be crazy if he survives this
you never know I just push me out I
didn't see a clear when maybe maybe I'm
just blind this is very easy now black
resides I did I didn't see it totally
clear winner after Knight f6 this is no
it doesn't work here look everyone he
has oh look at one it's a tricky defense
so Bishop f6 was wrong and I have no
wind that's so crazy why do I doesn't
fight every win in this position Luke f2
is is really amazing amazingly cheeky I
don't have a win yeah that's really
crazy look I have seven defended yeah
always the engine keeps white just a
little advantage after Bishop h4 look f
seven and then 93 90 f 61 g6 it's pretty
nice but it's still two pawns this is
what the engine is giving yeah that's
pretty dominating but it's still do
pawns have we get the H porn according
to the computer yeah okay so I think
I probably made a mistake somewhere here
not not here immediately but in the next
couple of moves i think i probably could
have played in a better way f3 is also
interesting for Bishop h3 of it and I
don't think this is particularly bad but
maybe around here there is some way to
improve now this is not super convincing
to be honest I mean it's it is a bit
better for white but I felt I should
have more I with this bit we had pawns
but them the computer only gives the 0.7
ok so this this shouldn't be too bad
yeah this is this is too risky there
should be six is given by the by the
engine ok this is stronger yeah this is
stronger because this forces basically
black to take and ok well the computer
actually wants to give an exchange j
which might be still rather tough for y2
to win this is I came the thing is what
else here I'm threatening to take him
and in this position I get these six end
to this Hanks and this is dangerous and
95 and everything yeah that's plus three
for my so Bishop e6 was very strong yeah
i played this Bishop e6 idea later but
this is not so convincing now the engine
gives me full compensation him but not
more and this is really crazy that then
black antique f2 I think but ok it just
seems to work and this this didn't work
because I'm yeah he could have taken
with the rook rook just have magic f1
okay this move I simply did not see and
after one rook is traded the
compensation fades away I'm just losing
now yes that was lucky still surprised
that he relatively quickly like after
six seconds played this maybe you just
didn't see that G seven assists is lost
I don't know when this is just losing
totally so you should try something I
wasn't even sure if you if they yeah the
computer also doesn't see a win after
this this is what I saw and but then
decided to just go for it anyway because
I didn't see an alternative but the
engine doesn't see a win here for wine
simply doesn't see one I can take the
end and then draw but this is Sir so
quite disappointing okay an interesting
game thanks for watching